pour tenter de contrer la transmission
des deux variants du coronavirus le port
du masque en extérieur a été rétablie à
paris dans plusieurs départements
métropolitains à lyon tours dijon en
loire atlantique ou en vendée mais ici
dans la capitale tout le monde n'a pas
encore compris la consigne même si les
contaminations en extérieur sont faibles
en proportion elle existe bel et bien en
france en mars dernier une étude de
l'institut pasteur révélé que les
contacts ayant entraîné une infection
avec lui à l'extérieur dans 5% des cas
ils parmi les masques les plus souvent
utilisés ou retrouve les modèles
chirurgicaux souple applis et les ff p2
plus rigide plus ajusté comme celui que
je porte ils sont beaucoup plus
filtrants il laisse donc moins passer
les particules virales et une étude
récente est éloquente considérons deux
personnes dans un lieu clos dont une
seule porte un masque est infecté il y à
bien 90% de chances d'être infecté pour
celle qui n'est pas malade dans le cas
où les deux individus porte à massy rue
j call le risque d'infection tombe à 30
% mais si les deux personnes son protégé
par un masque ffp2 le risque d'infection
passe à 0 4% d'autres études même si les
chiffres varient corrobore ces
constatations les experts le répète
comme il buisson président de la sia il
convient de 19 de l'académie nationale
de médecine dans les zones avec contacts
prolongés comme les transports le virus
et si transmissibles qu'il faut se
protéger avec un masque ffp2 il faudrait
plus communiquer sur ce point en toute
logique avec la déferlante omicron la
consigne de porter le fameux ffp2
devrait être de mise il est déjà
obligatoire dans certains lieux publics
en italie en grèce en autriche en
allemagne et pourtant en france on ne
pousse pas sa consommation tout juste en
tentant le conseil scientifique qui
recommande timidement aux personnes les
plus fragiles ou non vacciner dès que
cela est possible de porter des ffp2
rien de plus alors pourquoi ne pas
insister au regard de ces performances
incontestable et bien primo parce qu'ils
sont plus chers de trois à six fois le
prix des modèles chirurgicaux de 50 à 60
centimes en moyenne son port est en sus
un peu plus désagréable que celui des
chirurgicaux alors une nouvelle
injonction pourrait croiser les français
qui se sont déjà pour un grand nombre
d'entre eux montrés réfractaires aux
exhortations à se faire vacciner et à la
mise en place du pass sanitaires mais ce
n'est pas tout il y à bien aussi une
question de disponibilité
vous vous souvenez du scandale de la
pénurie de tous en début d'épidémie tco
vie la france avait rien pas de masque
pas de blouse pâte est depuis des unités
de fabrication de masques ont éclos
elles sont aujourd'hui une trentaine en
france les stocks destinés aux hôpitaux
ont été reconstituées mais les
industries du masque français sont loin
de répondre à la totalité de la demande
nous importons beaucoup par choix
stratégiques pour éviter de créer des
entreprises qui fermerait dès la fin de
l'épidémie si brutalement l'ordre du
port du havre p2 devait être donné aux
français il serait peut-être impossible
de s'en procurer suffisamment pourtant
le pays pourrait être autosuffisant
christan curel président du syndicat des
fabricants français de masques se montre
particulièrement optimiste
vous avez aujourd'hui entre 15 et 20
fabricant de ffp2 avec une production
d'au moins 20 millions de masques par
semaine on peut monter les rythmes en
fonction de l'accroissement de la
demande à noter selon le syndicat que
durant les étés 2020 et 2021 97 % des
appels d'offres ont finalement abouti au
choix des masques d'importation en
majorité commandé par des collectivités
ainsi le nombre de salariés français
fabriquant des masques a été amputé de
moitié ces derniers mois et la
fabrication des masques ffp2 en france a
quasiment été stoppée entre avril et
octobre 2021 avec une chute de la
production d'environ 90 % par rapport à
2020 selon les chiffres du syndicat
toutes ces raisons les réticences des
français le prix les pénurie prévisible
expliquent peut-être une communication
masqué si j'ose dire sur les ffp2 malgré
les données et le variant profitera
peut-être de ce flottement